HENRY SHACKLETON: So
collaboration for me was great.
My partner and I lived
on the same hall.
We lived right down the
hall from each other.
So we could very easily pop
over and talk to each other.
One thing that I found helpful--
that we actually
started messing up
a bit later on
throughout the semester--
was that your partner
is very good as a sort
of sanity check for you.
Which means that there's
a bit of a danger for you
and partner to start essentially
operating as one person,
and just like taking what your
other partner says for granted,
and using that in your data.
Because then you lose
that sanity check,
that that double-checking
of your data.
So it's important to work
together with your partner,
but also sort of constantly
be checking their work,
and verifying that what they're
doing is actually correct.